what should move forward in time with me
and what should be let go as if it's
Deadwood and the more Deadwood that you
let go of and burn off when you have the
opportunity the less it accretes around
you here here's something interesting
about forest fires you know people have
been trying to prevent forest fires for
a long time especially that damn bear
smokey right he's trying to prevent
forest fires
and so because forest fires burn up the
forest and that can't be good but here's
what happens if you don't let forest
fires burn is that
well forests collect a lot of dry
branches right because tree branches die
and wood falls on the forest floor and
collects and so the amount of flammable
material keeps increasing with time and
that's not so bad if it's wet but if the
amount of flammable material is
increasing and it gets really dry and
then it burns then you have a real
problem the forest fire can burn so hot
that it burns root does topsoil right
off in which case you don't have a
forest at all anymore you just have a
desert and lots of trees are evolved to
withstand forest fires of a certain
intensity and some won't even release
their seeds unless there's been a fire
and so a little bit of fire at the right
time can stop everything from burning to
the ground and that's also a really
useful insight a metaphorical insight
into the nature of sacrifice right it's
also a lot easier to let go of something
when you're deciding to let go of it
because you've decided yourself that
it's you're done with that it's a weak
part of you it needs to disappear you do
that yourself it's much better and much
easier than it is if it's taken away
from you forcibly in which case you're
very much likely to fight it these other
there's another interesting thing here a
motif that runs through the entire Bible
it's a very very powerful motif and it's
partly associated with this idea of
walking with or walking before God and
you know in the New Testament Christ
says something like the father's will be
done and he means that that will should
be done through him and so I can't I
won't
the state that's exactly right but it's
something like this you know a lot of
what people regard as their own
personalities and are proud of about
their own personalities aren't their own
personalities at all they're useless
idiosyncrasies that differ them
differentiate them trivially from other
people but they have no value in and of
themselves they're more like quirks I
remember once I was trying to teach a
particularly stubborn student about how
to write and she had written a number of
essays in in University and got
universally walloped for them and the
reason for that was she couldn't write
really at all she was really really bad
at writing and so I was sitting down
with her trying to explain to her what
she was doing wrong and she was being
very annoying about it very recalcitrant
very very unwilling to listen that was a
pearls before swine thing you know and
at one point she said it I can write
perfectly well this university
professors just don't like my style and
I could see all my hands creep towards
her neck yeah well then I'd be funny if
it wasn't true but was also true you
know when I thought what the hell's with
you you can't even write and you think
you have a style and not only do you
think ya know not knowing how to write
is not a style that's the other point
right and so you know she she instead of
humbling herself which was necessary and
okay right because she was a new
University students like of course you
don't know how to write when were you
gonna learn in school I don't think so
so she had this you know this this this
style issue and it it just it just
didn't go anywhere at all and so now
let's see I lost my train of thought and
telling you telling you all those jokes
oh yes in terms of above letting things
burn off yeah well so she was proud of
her insufficiency not arrogance right
that's not humility it's self-deception
and arrogance to be proud of your
insufficiency that's a very foolish
thing and that means to cling to the
parts of you that are dead
okay now there's this idea that runs
through the Bible I think as a whole
that okay I'll tell you another little
side story here I was reading about
Socrates today and I was reading about
Socrates trial you know he was tried by
the Athenians for corrupting for failing
to worship the correct gods and
corrupting the youth of Athens by like
teaching them stuff and asking them
questions you know it's just a great way
to corrupt people and so he knew the
trial was coming and Athens wasn't a
very big place only on about 25,000
people everybody knew everybody
everybody knew who the powerful guys
were and everybody including Socrates
knew that the trial was a warning do
like get out of town right we're going
to put you on trial in six months and
the potential penalty is death got that
it's like so so Socrates had a chat with
his compatriots and they were
contemplating fair means and foul to set
up a defense forum so that he could or
to leave so that he could not be tried
and put to death and he decided that he
wasn't going to do that and he also
decided that he wasn't going to even
think about his defense and he said why
this is quite an interesting thing he
said why he told one of his friends that
he had this voice in his head a demon
the spirit something like that that he
always listened to and that that was one
of the reasons he was different from
other people because he always listened
to this thing it didn't tell him what to
do but it told him what not to do it
always told him what not to do and if it
told him not to do something then he
didn't do it if he was speaking and the
little voice came up and said not know
then he shut up and he tried to say
something else and he was very emphatic
about this and he said that when he
tried to
plan to evade the trial or even to mount
his own defense the voice came up and
said no don't bother with it and he
thought well what would he what the hell
do you mean by that like there's a trial
coming and I'm going to be put to death
and well he eventually concluded that he
was an old guy you know the next 10
years he was in his 70s perhaps the next
10 years weren't going to be that great
for him he got a chance maybe the gods
were giving him a chance just to bow out
you know to put his affairs in order to
say good bye to everyone to avoid that
last descent into catastrophe which
might have been particularly painful for
a philosopher and to and to walk off the
world on his own terms
something like that the point I'm making
with that is that Socrates attended to
this internal voice that at least told
him what not to do and then he didn't do
it and of course Socrates was a very
remarkable man and we still hear about
him today and we know that he existed
and all of those things and so back to
the back to the walking with God idea
you know as you elevate your aim you
create a judge at the same time right
because the new ideal which is an ideal
you even if it's just an ideal position
that you might occupy even if it's still
conceptualized in that concrete way that
becomes a judge because it's above you
right and then you're you're terrified
of it maybe that's why you might be
afraid when you go start a new job right
because your this thing is above you and
you're terrified of it and it judges you
and that's useful because that's the
judge that you're creating by
formulating the ideal tells you what's
useless about yourself and then you can
dispense with it and you want to keep
doing that and then every time you make
a judge that's more elevated then
there's more useless you that has to be
dispensed with and then if you pre
create an ultimate judge which is what
the archetypal imagination of humankind
has done say with the figure of Christ
because if Christ is nothing else he is
at least the archetypal perfect man and
therefore the judge you have a judge
that says
get rid of everything about yourself
that isn't perfect of course that's also
what Abraham that's also what God tells
Abraham right he says to be perfect to
pick an ideal that's high enough and you
can do this the thing that's interesting
about this I think is you can do it more
or less on your own terms
you have to have some collaboration from
other people but you don't have to pick
an external ideal you can pick an ideal
that fills the role of ideal for you you
can say okay well if things could be set
up for me the way I need them to be and
if I could be who I needed to be what
would that look like and you can figure
that out for yourself and then instantly
you have a judge and I also think that's
part of the reason people don't do it
right why don't why don't people look up
and move ahead an answer is well you
know you start formulating an ideal you
formulate a judge it's pretty easy to
feel intimidated in the face of your own
ideal that's what happens to Kane vs
Abel for example then it's really easy
to destroy the ideal instead of to try
to pursue it because then you get rid of
the judge but it's way better lower the
damn judge if it's too much like if your
current ambition is crushing you you
know then maybe you're playing the
tyrant to yourself and you should tap
down your ambitions not get rid of them
by any stretch of the imagination but at
least put them more reasonably within
your grasp you don't have to leap from
point one to point 50 in one leap right
you can do it incrementally but I really
like this idea I think it's a profound
idea that the process of recapitulating
yourself continually is also the process
of it's a phoenix-like process right
you're shedding all those elements of
you that are no longer worthy of the
pursuits that you're that you're valuing
and then I would say the idea here is
that as you do that you shape yourself
ever more precisely into something that
can withstand the tragedy of life and
that can act as a as a beacon to the
world that's the right way of thinking
about it maybe first to your friends and
then to your family it's like it's a
hell of a fine ambition and there's no
reason that it can't happen you know
every one of you knows people who are
really bloody useful in a crisis and
people that you admire right those are
all you can think of all those P
allows you admire that you admire us
partial incarnations of the archetypal
Messiah that's exactly right and the
more that that manifests itself in any
given person then the more generally
useful and admirable that person is in a
multitude of situations and we don't
know the limit to that but people can be
unbelievably good for things you know
it's really something to behold